Hey James, what do you say about treating a displayProjects function that will
handle all of our projects and display them on a page?
>> I have a better idea.
We only just touch the surface of what objects can do.
Let's take a look at them first, and
then we'll finish off our resume using our newfound knowledge of objects.
Does that work for you?
>> Yeah.
Why don't you start us off?
>> We saw earlier that we define objects with these curly braces.
And we also include code for functions inside the curly braces.
Guess what?
Functions are objects.
>> What?
>> I know you knew that already.
It's a little bit crazy, but pretty much everything in JavaScript is really
an object when you get right down to it.
There's a link in the instructor's notes with implications from
the relationship between functions and object.
For our purposes it's useful to note that objects can
encapsulate functions as well.
>> Yeah.
For instance, let's create display as a method of the projects object.
Projects, the object,
already includes all of our data about all of the projects we've completed.
And now it's going to include a function that will help us display
those projects.
Using dot notation here,
we can add a new property to the projects object called display.
And we'll set it equal to a function.
Within these curly braces, we'll define what the function display will do.
Even though we defined the projects object with object literal notation,
it doesn't matter how we defined the projects object,
we can still crreate this property display using dot notation.
This is called encapsulation,
meaning that we're holding the display function inside the projects object.
It's a nice way to organize our code into logical domains and
JavaScript makes it really easy to do so.
>> Nice.
So what should go inside projects.display?
>> Hm, you know what?
Let's let the students decide first.